let's have a look through and you guys
remember we've talked about this before
um there's always something to learn
from all of this right so we'll go
through one at a time
our sending order ascending before we
get to the answer
what does ascending mean like could
someone give me a definition yeah i'm a
means going up
very good so i might ascend the
staircase which means i go from the
bottom
and then i'll end up at the top okay
which means that my numbers
should start with the smallest numbers
and then go up to the biggest ones does
that make sense
do they look okay what do you think
that's hot list
does that look ascending to you thumbs
up i agree it's a bit weird that 26 and
the 10
they look like big numbers but they're
very negative which means on the number
line they're on the
left side right very good so happy with
that one
descending of course means the opposite
so we're starting with the
big numbers and we're climbing down does
it look good what do you think of the
order
yeah happy one two fantastic
okay let's have a look at our adding and
subtracting you did adding with me mrs
bartlett
uh took over when we looked at
subtraction one plus seven i think we're
happy with um just normal positive
numbers
two take away five now negative three
hands up if you've got negative three it
ends up straight
yeah cool a lot of you hands down i'm
going to do this one because it'll help
us understand what's going on with this
next one right
when you've got and i would actually
like you even though you didn't need to
do a number line when you you're working
on the questions i'd like you to draw a
number line now
so just draw one beside if you have the
right answer perhaps especially if
you've got the right answer
what does two take away five mean
on the number line first step what's the
most important number
on the number line zero always zero so i
think
hannah will put that guy in the middle
okay now if i want
two minus five two minus five means i'm
gonna start from here
and then i'm going to move somewhere
depending on what this is telling me
a distance and a direction because these
are directed numbers after all right
so i'm going to put 2 1 2 there's my
starting point
i need a few more other marks on here so
i'm going to put a few more at equal
distances
i don't know how many i need just yet
once you've got those marks there
if you have another color that would be
great i'm going to start from
two it's a really messy tube let's fix
that
and then i'm going to go in which
direction which reaction am i going to
go into yeah
i'm going to go to the left minus means
go to the left okay
and i'm going to go five times so let's
count them right
one two three four five that's where i
end up
okay that's my take away five so you can
see there's the distance
and the direction okay so remembering
that i already put zero in that spot
where am i now i know yeah
yeah very good um negative three
negative one negative two negative three
keep in mind it is negative three and
not minus three what's the difference
between those again they're different
kinds of words does anyone remember yeah
negative means like when it's um not a
positive integer but it's a negative
zero
and then subtract or minus is
related to subtract when you want to
take away something yeah very good so
just going back to that right
negative is about the number right it's
equality that
it's an adjective if you remember that
little english lesson that we did before
whereas minus is not an adjective
minus and subtract uh what kind of words
again there
starts with a v you all tell me and
they're verbs right it's an action word
something is happening
between two different things and there's
not two different things here it's just
the number
and i'm describing it okay all right so
this will help us understand
what's going on here okay negative 14
isn't quite right but
where would we get negative 14 from like
that's not a ridiculous answer
even though it's not quite correct can
someone help me understand how we could
have gotten that yeah it might
when we're adding yeah very good so 3
plus 7
is 14 right and then we've done the
minus sign out the front so even though
it's not correct
at least we can see where it came from
how would i do this correctly what could
i do instead yeah daniel
yeah very good so i'm starting at
negative three that's convenient it was
the answer to my previous one
and then i'm going to go 11 in this
direction okay
now i need to extend my number line a
little bit maybe you want to extend
yours just a teeny bit too
so you can see here if i were to go
where's my green gun
it's disappeared that's sad um i'll use
black instead
if i'm gonna go 11 to the which way
which way am i going
which way i'm going to the right because
it's a
plus right i'm going to count them out
can you help me okay
one count two two three
four four five five six seven
eight eight nine ten 11 11. there's the
last one
and you can count em right you can see
i'm going to end up at
eight are you happy with that does that
make sense okay so we have an answer for
this one
what do you guys think of the rest of
them are you happy with them yes
yeah looking okay uh minus four that's
where you're gonna start and you're
gonna go
even more to the left and then this guy
here what's going on here what's this
business about
a double negative a double negative what
what's a double negative signify for us
yeah
it's going to become plus do you
remember i gave you an analogy for that
last time what was the picture analogy i
showed you a movie too
what's that like we looked it up
and we're we're taking away something
that's swaying us
down so the result is it gets bigger
okay and six is indeed bigger